パッ
たださんお疲れした方もいますどうしました今日
今日した肇社長にあの言わなきゃいけないことができましたん
どうしましたあの
まあいいところですよアーネットから札静岡ですよね
普段静岡ですね静岡 a 的とかねやっぱパンの人がきちゃって困るっていうことで
看板作ったりとかしてもお母さんですねはだからもちろん観させていただいてますよ
ですねあでもまああんなのもねお金もかかって大変だろうなあと思いながら見てるん
ですけどもまぁあと
これとかねえっこれねこういうものとか
謎の高いですね人ですねこれ飾ってやってるとかわかんないですよ私には勝はこれ
ちょっとお高いものですよねこういう面ですみますたがこういうものとかも
どうやって変えるのかということですけどもやっぱ肇社長チャンネル多くの人が見て
くれてるわけですよおかげさまで見てくれているからいろんなことができるんですよ
その人たちに対してねやっぱりあの
定期的にやっている質問コーナーじゃないですか
ねえ
本郷なぁ
新たその質問コーナー今やってないですよね
3月にはやるって言ってましたよね
3月中に出さ
以上募集のやつでは
やろうと言ってましたで今何月ですか
5月ですね
お忙しいのはわかりますユーチューバーの皆さん本当に毎日毎日テレビの仕事がもあり
ますし
何やったんさ
何か月ん
いい理由にはなるんですけどん
やっぱり他の仕事とか別の撮影で
ちゃんと時間が作れなかったなっていう部分は
う
あるいは原点である youtube それを支えてくれているファンの皆様よりも
大切な仕事があった
急いで2ヶ月も遅れたっ
たいという気持ちはあったんですけど気持ちは同行者文字装備やってないんですね
せめてもう千家なるほどー
ひどい裏切りですね同じ口座がですねこれとかねぇ
皆さんのほうがいいですかねこれそうですよね
みなさんが見てくれてるおかげでこういうものをはじめしゃちょー手に入れているので
いつもはにちょっと羌活を入れるために質問コーナーをちゃんとやってもらうために来
ました皆さんのために
あーやっぱね皆さんちゃんとはじめたちのことを応援し続けてほしいので
ということでした
なのでへと早急に質問コーナーをやってください
ない場合はこれ私いただきます
米門の償還はいただきますと必ず
やりますよないように
お願いしますこと待ってますか皆さん
あー肇社長なんかテレビの人になっちゃった女たちすごいま寂しい思いをしていますよ
ぜ
と言うとそうした方がいいと思います
英語でじゃあ今日肇社長質問コーナー答えてくれるそうなので渡子ちゃんと一人主張し
て測りますので安いよろしければ山田さんも一緒に出てもらうことができないんですか
質問コーナー
流れ的な人おかしいと思うんですけど k あの
結構無茶生まれ
そうですねちゃぷり多い者
静雄に
ほぼ
操り人形みたいな感じでありますけどそれはでも俺どうかなぁ
言ってもねあのー
結婚して子供もいますお忙しいのも頭痛そうなんですけどあのね事務所にも
私もジム砂得もしてるけどね
俳優としてご飯たちもいっぱいいる中で
できることできないことはありますよ申し上げますあの
号令なことはです
もうセンサーまたにゃまあまあ全然でも実はもう肇社長のやっぱこうチャンネル待って
くれ呈していますし始めたじゃんねあのメンツにもかかるボタンで協力できることはし
ます
あったら無茶はちゃったまでげさ
映像やってもらっ
俺が言って本当にやってくれるのであるをれた帰ったらやらないでしょ
テレビの仕事やっちゃうでしょ
テベスしかちゃうと言うだろ矢口じゃあやるじゃあやる
いいねらー無茶はしないよわかりましたもちろんします山中ができる範囲で入らせて
いただきます
んじゃ行くと協力させていただきますやっぱ
tee
ええええええ
一緒に撮ろう
どんどんためで女だった舞台に逃げる
[音楽]
持った
ええええええ
ん
[音楽]
ええええええ
ていました
tee